tengo a más de que multiplica
de entre paréntesis igual a a veces más
b de esto de aquí representa cuál de las
siguientes propiedades y bueno aquí
tengo estas tres propiedades asociativa
combativa o distributiva ahora observa
que para llegar del lado izquierdo al
lado derecho de esta expresión lo que
hice fue multiplicar a benz porsche y
también
avn por d esa fue muy buena idea de
hecho lo que hice fue distribuir la vez
en temas de y con eso obtuve vez en más
de us y que esto claramente es la
propiedad distributiva muy bien vamos a
hacer varios ejercicios más así que
déjame quitar este de aquí y ahora vamos
a trabajar con este que dice cuatro más
paréntesis 10 más 6 esto es igual a 4 10
en paréntesis
esto equipo representa cuál de las
siguientes propiedades
entonces en el lado izquierdo en esta
parte tengo que hacer primero 10 más 6 y
a esto sumarle 4 y en el lado derecho
tengo que hacer primero 4 10 ya esto
sumarle 6 estas son expresiones iguales
no importa cómo asociamos estos números
aquí en este caso estamos asociando el
10 más 6 primero y después le sumamos 4
y acá de este lado estamos asociando el
4 más 10 primero y después le sumamos 6
así que esta es la propiedad asociativa
de la suma muy bien vamos a hacer uno
más ahora tengo a más b es igual además
a esto representa cuáles las siguientes
propiedades
entonces si observas no importa en qué
orden sumen no importa si es más bien o
de massa voy a obtener el mismo
resultado esto se le conoce como la
propiedad conmutativa así que mi
respuesta va a ser propia
conmutativa muy bien y vamos a hacer
varios más déjame quitar este y ahora
vamos a trabajar con este cuál de las
siguientes expresiones representa la
propiedad asociativa de la suma la
propiedad asociativa de la suma así que
recuerda si estamos hablando de la
propiedad asociativa entonces no importa
como asociamos los números por lo tanto
podemos hacer la operación primero de
dos números y después un tercero o
primero otros dos de esos números y el
restante después así que veamos cuál de
éstos cumple con eso si observamos esta
de aquí está bueno la acabamos de ver es
la propiedad conmutativa así que no va a
ser mi respuesta esto de aquí tampoco va
a ser mi respuesta porque es la
propiedad distributiva y este de aquí
observa en el lado izquierdo tengo
primero demás esto de aquí y a esto le
sumamos a y del lado izquierdo tengo a
más b primero y después le sumamos c y
como estas dos expresiones son iguales
no importa como asociemos si asociamos
primero de más y después le sumamos a o
si asociamos primero a master y después
le sumamos el entonces esta de aquí es
la propiedad asociativa de la suma muy
bien vamos a hacer uno más ahora tengo
este de aquí cuál de las siguientes
expresiones representa la propiedad
distributiva de la suma sobre la
multiplicación y bueno veamos este de
aquí como ya dijimos es el que asocian
estar acá es la propiedad conmutativa
así que debe de ser ésta y si observas
aquí estamos distribuyendo esta vez
sobre cm más de porque ven por semanas
de es lo mismo que ves en más venden así
que es esta de aquí está aquí es mi
respuesta correcta muy bien vamos a
hacer uno más y ahora tengo esta de aquí
y bueno otra vez
no importa cómo estemos asociando no
importa si primero tomamos demás y
después
o si tomamos a más de mí y después le
sumamos el no importa cómo sea los
tiempos los números porque eso es lo que
nos dice la propiedad asociativa muy
bien así que vamos a hacer uno más y
este es el último cuál de las siguientes
expresiones representa la propiedad
conmutativa de la suma la propiedad
conmutativa de la suma bueno pues la
propiedad conmutativa quiere decir que
no importa el orden en el cual nos
tomemos a los números a los cuales les
vamos a aplicar la operación en este
caso es la suma así que esta sería mi
respuesta correcta a más bien es igual
además a no importa el orden en el cual
vamos a aplicar la suma a estos dos
números y ya está
ya con esto acabamos el vídeo